In der britischen Stadt Leicester sind am
Sonntag bei einer schweren Explosion zwei Gebäude zerstört worden.
Die Behörden sprachen von einem "schweren
Zwischenfall" und hatten die Bürger zunächst
aufgefordert, das betroffene Gebiet zu meiden.
Alle verfügbaren Rettungskräfte seien im
Einsatz, hatte es geheißen.
Über die Ursache der Detonation wurden zunächst
keine Angaben gemacht.
Den Rettungsdiensten zufolge wurden vier Menschen
mit Verletzungen in Krankenhäuser gebracht.
Ein Augenzeuge berichtet:
"Das erste, was ich gesehen habe, war das
zerstörte Geschäfte und die kaputte Bushaltestelle auf der anderen Seiten.
Überall lagen Trümmer.
Und sehr schnell danach brach ein Feuer aus."
Bei dem Vorfall wurden mehrere Gebäude beschädigt,
Anwohner mussten in Sicherheit gebracht werden.
Zum gegenwärtigen Zeitpunkt gebe es keine
Hinweise darauf, dass der Vorfall einen terroristischen
Hintergrund habe, sagte ein Polizeisprecher.